twitter e posso mettermi in vendita a
risaltare cosi cobas alle insegnanti
chiamo che sono le mie amiche molto
somiglianti presentare un altro video
lei claudia nelle valentina che vedere
su instagram hanno una patina che si
chiama gemelle martin e pensieri non
vediamo se riescono a raggiungere i 1000
foto mi raccomando andate a seguirle
allora ci facciamo una challenge è molto
particolare inventato da me so che loro
non hanno mai fatto lo slalom
io andrò a ben d'armi e darò loro le
istruzioni per fare lo slime passo passo
dopo io mi vedo così almeno non le vede
non è corretto alla fine quando lo slime
è pronto mi tolgo la benda e vedo che
cosa hanno combinato che vedono anche
chi ha vinto cioè di piero tra il
migliore se di valentino
nome di claudia e anche voi potete anche
perché loro non un'idea di una strada
rimane professioni ancora più divertente
perché penso che c'era un disastro ma
non lo so ma vedersi la bellissimo chi
lo stop anche voi voterete alla fine del
video dei commenti quale l'eni
prescritti e sicuri di valentina quelle
di cloud e così vediamo chi non c'è
quindi mi raccomando siate pronti come
sempre lasciate un like se volete vedere
altri video challenge 10.000 likes nuovi
video challenge e ora sente pronto ad e
valentina ok io vivendo la penna tutti
finché ci sono qua io che lasciano bella
non vi dico quali sono gli ingredienti 1
è più facile c'è altro che sorprende
nessuno
ok iniziamo prendete la folla potete
scegliere o bianco trasparente non dite
quello che fate scena perché sono io
l'ho detto prendete
non mi sveglio e se ho con la mia dopo
la trasferta mettetele con tavolette
basta che non rendite cosa fino all'orlo
quello questo paese che è imparato
tantissimo da me io perché tutto troppo
direttamente si potesse scegliere se
mettere o la schiuma da barba o vicenda
guardo ricche questa la panna montata
[Musica]
dubbio che dell'umore che mi candido
ora prendete la foto la iniziate già mi
piace invece in casa e questo stile
insomma abbiamo pensato per mostri ma
l'abbiamo capito se volete aggiungete la
trappola o bianco trasparente
ma ritorniamo per noi si senta
io non so se penso che la pensa
esistenza sia questa non è una scusa
invece dopo che proprio il nostro ok
quindi avete mischiate bene allora
adesso potete prendere il colorante
tricolore sta attenti perché qui
coloranti che lo sono messi su per male
tranne un paio ne ho un paio in borsetta
che ho trovato invece anche questi corte
facciamo del film colore oppure no no mi
dite niente consiste in tempo ho preso
un colore illegali non lo so perché
tutto e pasticciate del dell'alcol e
proprio viso deve dimettere
quindi si sa pochissimo proprio non
pomentino uscirò ma sto facendo noi
aspetta progetto la puntino le banche
sporcarlo un pochino quasi solo un po di
riva magari si metta una puntina e
lavezzi innamorato della messa alla
porta si gira cosa facevi schiantato
cucchiaino dentro se non un nonno perché
questo suscita però officina punti devo
dire che quel entrambi alla camera ma
non è così
e mi chiedo se ci aiuta ma quello che
più compatto come la si sconfigge più e
molto liquido sento bene da tutti col 2
scegli tu eppure bastava mente la
situazione attuale ma roseline non
fatelo vedere alla camera bastardi sala
sempre di lettere che questo parlamento
ha preso sito conseguite nessun colore
troppo ma secondo me le bravissime
ora potete aggiungere un po di l'opzione
tutti diventerà profumato dell'astico né
si fermano xvi oggi ha reperiti stiamo
ultimando di qualcosa che nessuno
indietro finendo ancora ministro di una
lazio
sto cercando di rendere pietre di colore
perché a meno che comincia sempre
edilizia che le molte più cose
[Musica]
domani in termini di funzioni nel reboot
perché hanno l'orante malefico assurde
sporche che immaginiamo colpe davanti
all time e colorato allora zizzi
ok ora potete scegliere una decorazione
a questa scelta e posso mettermi ok al
contempo la bellona possono sperare in
qualcosa di scolo rock ma anche tanto
sarà mai più
ma veniamo quella scena mettereste della
decorazione 104 logicamente le falìe che
cadono in qualcosa di solido il nostro
dal tavolo prendete glitter
fate clic twitter mentre incompleta tv
con la simbologia mettere quanta
debolezza del tessuto
si no veloso
allora se volete potete aggiungere altri
kit quindi possiamo rischiare colori si
che siete soddisfatti con le doti di
glitter
ho 21 anni assistono frutti subito non è
tutto rosa
volevo io non tocco lo rende un po
stupido
definiamo cioè si vede quali ho giocato
io perché sono impegnati di più più
famoso chef allora opzionalmente se
volete potete leggere un'altra
decorazione quindi scegliete pure
un'altra decorazione sembrerebbe che
metterà a vedere se poi magari prima
telo finite proverò a illuminare con la
bella cosa teme moltissimo anche
sostenute mentre altri e di qualità
liberamente si somma con la potete
vedere che questa non è bello non è
profumata conveniente rebellin
nel momento meno belli ma non è il mio
caso il problema che e non possono
sentire lo stesso consumatore non è
molto glamour e sperano che intesa però
non mi dispiace nel sole in quell'atto
non mi vidi questo schiuma da barba
brillantini o detrazioni perché questa è
alla fine e poi andiamo ad attivarlo
quindi state aggiunte altre cose si è
spenta mi aggiustando correnti che
ciao 22 20 iniziali presentata quelli
claudia per mature questa fetta della
sua consistenza è quella giusta la mia
del cielo rimane occhiello e tronto io
non so che avete messo nostra con gli
ingredienti quindi non vi tostare
quest'anno giuste però e voi dovete
continuare ad aggiungere finché non si
solidificato primo potete cambiare
l'ordine comunque la soluzione per lenti
che conoscete xkè 28 bel po che non lo
stop e poi in pratica si attiva con la
soluzione per lenti e il bicarbonato di
sodio che non voleva non ne va messo
troppo ma dipende dal cantante
devo aggiungere allora perché la
soluzione parlanti sto facendo un rumore
strano ma se siete anche lì la quantità
dell'epoca soluzione salina dipende la
panca con l'altra qualità con la questa
pratica
piano piano si ha sempre un pochino di
più che non siamo pronti magari più o
meno ok che o meno di key longari mariti
o meno scalette per meglio un'altra
mostra diventa durissimo non vi dico
quale forse si
[Musica]
adesso mischiate bene e vedete se sta
iniziando a vinh turisti un po le linee
di giudicarmi sembra come il colore
veramente orribile
[Musica]
ma che mette
una volta coccolare un po una maniera
investito meglio tuo viene affrontato
negli ficano questo mio nome a catania
allora ricambiato lo ha commesso per
continuare ad aggiungere le soluzioni
per tutti quindici persone non di case
si solidifica quindi mettete una
contrazione mischiate questa è la parte
più complicata quindi dopo questa
abbiamo finito quando si stacca
completamente dalla ciotola e non è più
appiccicoso
poi il tecnico conosce notte vi
metterete soluzione tempo era pizzico di
bicarbonato qualcuno che si nota un
giorno mikado succedendo qualcuno che
basti cederlo ma che ci so dire perché
non so se lo fate vedere allora
perché non lo sanno solo il braccio
salisse non è lo stop è però fatto che
mancano ma allora non so ma la mia
consistenza un in piena c'è anche serve
quella giusta
[Musica]
ok non so voi ma non so veramente
consistenza sa questa è tratto la pizzi
che io non mi sognerei della via che
oggi a mettere la ballerina e non si
attacca aiuti
non so se deve essere così è stata era
completamente da un altro mondo l'asti
perché hanno un po tanto io
a me non pare che perda dei componenti
[Musica]
dalla somma si perde allora io so se sia
normale completa delle perline
utilizzato la chicca che forse non è
solo all'area che dico io quello stesso
se lo meritano i quadrati siano proprio
marito che pagano su tutto questo
oddio non tutti mettendo non potete
piangere e decorazioni non ho messo
anche quelle commesse di mille questo
momento io meramente roma lusso che
definire anche claudia e poi arriviamo
perché era stanco lazio ormai va bene ci
sono
dai permette la macchina rimetto con la
bendata una fede pellone marca ma il
primato ora è questo è il video un cast
davvero grande
non mi sembra un po fisico piccoli io
il figlio e 18 e mi ripetevo tocca
allora mi sembra un bel po craxi però ci
può essere ottimo attore perché troppo
piccoli e respiro che tante palline
dentro quanto volta per amore si parte
vengono poi soluzione per lenti va bene
ok ora tocca a me è ok
questo è il mio dio
questo questo è pronto ho i miei sensato
di bicarbonato forse un po in turista
vede perché non si inchina si passerà
mostra se ne presenti questo mi chiamo
altro genere era già pronto con alfredo
di abusarne sicuramente però fino
raggiungere alcune vantaggio costituiti
vedere me vale di secondo la inventò le
recentissime valore assoluto quindi
avrebbe dovuto di gerardo santoli tra me
e io toglietelo custodire in ogni notte
mi sembra pezzi tutti un raffronto
aggiungere io potevo sogna di darla che
di un po
[Musica]
ecco allora come consistenza questo è
uscito molto bene si vede bene che cosa
che anche voi questa di valentina come
consistenza e sta molto bene ed è usato
la palla trasparente vero tutte e due a
e io sono con la trasparenza il mio meno
quelle decorazioni quella greca per me
sì perché hai messo posso numero di
carbonato di sodio e quindi non si è
indurito troppo comunque date un voto da
1 a 10 a quello di valentina questo qua
che raccomandiamo che ha dovuto
aggiungere per il ricatto regalo
interiore
ma poiché il miglioramento non
attaccheremo dall'inizio perché come
quel problema è che diventano zucca
colle molta schiuma da barba
c'erano due consistente un po sciolto e
quindi su molto attivo attore perché si
strappa un peccato per cui diciamo non
possa portarlo a casa perché riempire la
valigia
so benissimo cosa cinque minuti
faravelli scusa fanno vedere quindi loro
possono da tempo la e chi ha fatto
meglio le migliori che un effetto più
già messo in particolare organizzate si
sta montando se lassù della cervella il
cervello di lucoli occhio la
rappresentazione nei commenti date un
voto a quello di valentine a quello di
claudia poi mai sapere chi ha vinto
secondo me ha bisogno di commenti
tutti i diritti divertiti in questo di
vendita un sacco
faccio tutto bene se volete vedere altri
anche ghezzal e se volete vedere e mi
lascio rampa neri quali cui potete
vedere anderson e altri video divertenti
il cane eppure queste quattro caselle e
primo amiat e quindi scusa per i ranghi
degli sly e meno bisogna dividere la
spazzatura
rimaniamo in basso e la prossima
[Musica]